how to create the simplest mapping  pipeline so that you get an expression  table at the end so here I am and create  RNA seek pipeline what I'm gonna do is  select PE fast queue files and change it  to human I'm gonna upload some files and  I already have some uploaded files so  I'm just gonna go to find some input  file put files present okay so here are  some files already uploaded on the  server and then what I'm gonna do is  cancel no groups so this is what the  pipeline should look like start bowtie  to tee I'm mapping unknown transcripts  that are already in the in the known  genome in that human genome that I have  then our seven expression table now here  I can check FP cam or change it to  something else  okay and then end and that's it that's a  pipeline that is going to run fast it's  going to just give me expression of  known genes and it's going to produce a  table of expression gene ID and a  quantified number of map reads onto that  tube